et non ouais hello je hais ce qu'est ce
que vous parlez français par mots à vous
tardez pas français mais quand ça se
fait je vous comprends parce que je
parle un anglais traduit en français
avant d'accord avec mais quand vous
parlez anglais alors qu'est ce que ça
donne sur l'espagnol à bord on how do
you do you de poils et niola matelas ah
bah ça va on a très bien s'entendre
alors si vous le voulez bien nous allons
réaliser au pour les téléspectateurs
une recette une recette franco-anglaise
poids qui s'intitule d'ailleurs en
français la terrine de jeu les deux
merles s'emmerde et en anglais le
water-polo
alors nous allons essayer de réaliser
deux concerts cette recette
bassila nous avons pris des notes
d'espoir nounours manière à ce qu'il n'y
ait pas d'équivoque en or milady voulez
vous qu'on commence si on nous prenait 1
litre d'eau ordinaire mais vous avez
pris soin de faire préalablement
bouillie l'adaptant attend dé voir c'est
bien mouillé oui c'est bien beau dit
alors un litre contre moi un livre là
dedans vous saviez un imam j'ai pas
alors un demi-litre voilà et un second
demi litre
voilà que ce sont les éléments
fondamentaux de la cuisine anglaise
alors deuxièmement un deuxième alors je
vais vous conter les biens bouillant fin
on a vu qu'elle est et gabri d'ailleurs
quand on met la main dans son rapport
vous prenez la seconde litres d'eau oui
que voici que vous faites tiédir obama
rixe effet il est une aide
il est héritier novanano fait verser un
autre litres d'eau fraîche dans l'autre
ok mais c'est ça alors c'est ça mais
moussa abou dabous goutte-à-goutte 8 à
gauche pour que ça fasse une bonne
saison
assayas des grumeaux n'a jamais décroché
dès lors elle remplacée alors maintenant
alors roulé ce matin légèrement épaissir
salaire net et qu'on le mette en doute
est en bois légèrement épaissir sur le
coin du feu du noël alors que lost en
irak est abandonné c'est ça ou monter en
neige
ah bon il trentino obama est alors monté
ça
c est pourquoi
de là on n'a pas attaché nous ne savons
pas ce qu'il faut éviter que ça à faire
oui mais alors il faut l'incorporation
l'incorporer dans la glace et avait
atterri samedi matin faux démouler bon
alors
roger boulay est pour et pour wii et
pour clarifier vous des délégués de
danse invite au bond la balle alors
qu'elle à la ronde initiale
vous avez ce qu'on apprenne un concentré
de mairie de gelée de même lui qui est
de donner sa force de concentration ne
permet pas son utilisation dans la
cuisine ça c'est pas possible si l'on
veut s'en servir il faut allonger avec
avec les tendres ou avec de l'eau de
l'eau quelques comptes audités dans la
propension de gros comme la tête d'al
ain sur la panne des dépenses militaires
alors comme ça ça n'a renseigné et
passer tout bon vieux iphone il faut il
faut quand même
voilà comment leurs excréments là vous
obtenez un concentré de zinder que vous
allez tendre bien entendu avec plusieurs
lettres de tendre et alors si on y gère
pas bien si on ne gère pas bien là y'a
qu'à boire un verre d'eau 40
opiniâtre
j'ai suivi mes français
le dimanche
[Musique]